Vanessa Bryant has reached a settlement
with Los Angeles County over graphic
photos that were shared from the
helicopter crash that killed her husband
Kobe Bryant and their daughter Gianna
going Gigi
for Vanessa's lawyer L.A county has
agreed to pay Vanessa and her three
daughters Natalia Bianca and Capri
28.85 million dollars which includes the
15 million they were awarded by a jury
last summer I've learned the most just
from each other I think just being able
to rely on each other and be there for
each other has been like the biggest
inspiration after Vanessa learned that
LA County officers shared graphic photos
of human remains from the January 2020
crash they sued for negligence and
invasion of privacy that September
Vanessa won a trial last August I think
the more significant
of it is
much whether or not they were supposed
to take those photos but the mere fact
that anyone else would have seen them is
the big problem regardless of whether or
not they were legitimately taking those
photos in the first place and the
statement shared with ET by her attorney
he says this marks the end of the Bryant
family's fight for those who lost their
lives in the horrific crash quote she
fought for her husband her daughter and
all those in the community whose
deceased family were treated with
similar disrespect we hope her victory
at trial and this settlement will put an
end to this practice I've actually heard
people say this is like a money grab and
I I to me that's the craziest thing to
hear can you just imagine one of your
loved ones having photos taken of your
child and your husband with the body
parts separated and knowing that someone
at a bar where someone was having a
casual beer was casually shown a photo
of your loved one I would not settle so
what's going to happen with the money
well some of it's going to a cause close
to the family's heart in August days
after the jury awarded the cash to
Vanessa and her family her lawyer
announced that she plans to give an
unspecified amount to the Mamba and
mombasito sports Foundation a non-profit
that continues Kobe and Gianna's
legacies by offering opportunities to
underprivileged Young athletes Sports is
such a thing that could bring a family
together versus looking at things in
isolation right yes it's a place for
kids to reach their full potential yeah
but it's also a place for families to
come and trust that this is a facility
where they can they can they can they
can trust that their kids are in the
best care right that's really important
because there's a lot of things out
there for your children that you're not
sure about so that's what we try to
create following August trial win
Vanessa shared this photo with Kobe and
Janna in honor of their Victory with the
caption all for you I love you justice
for Kobe and Gigi
foreign